[Music]
foreign
officer Captain Seth dozerman my motto
is simple efficiency efficiency
efficiency could probably just say it
once are you making fun of my stutter oh
uh direct you I don't have a stutter
boom I've already established my
authority through my amazing sense of
humor well done sir welcome to the nine
nine I'm Sergeant Terry Jeffers and I'm
not interested I have no use for people
I find people weird and confusing I Live
My Life by Numbers you see this watch it
tells me how many calories I burn at any
time question how many calories you
think I burned walking from there to
there you female closest to me oh uh
three three
try 0.8 numb nuts I made promises to my
superiors that I most certainly cannot
keep that's why I need you idiots to
work twice as hard no no strike that
four times as hard no no strike that I
need you morons to work eight times
harder than you've ever
will retire
I'm having a heart attack
yeah I'm having a heart attack get back
to work
get a doctor holy Moses he's alive so I
want to explain what happened back there
I did not have a heart attack the
doctors have informed me that I have a
genetic heart condition my aortic valve
is 16 too narrow
which lowers my life expectancy from 103
to 64. so sorry sir that's terrible yes
it's depressing
he also informed me that I carry the
gene for webbed feet it's just
interesting more than anything else
when you stare death in the face
as I have it really puts things into
perspective namely that I've been
wasting too much of my time farting
around so that stops now say goodbye to
the fun hilarious laid-back set those
are men that you used to love always
hand them out
hell are these what the hell are these
These are Dozer pads each one is
equipped with a GPS system and a
countdown clock to remind you to
complete a task every 55 minutes it also
has backgammon on it which I could not
delete but you are not allowed to play
What happens when the clock Runs Out
oh that's fun yeah your 55 minutes
starts right
now
captain
everything all right
[Applause]
you tell me according to your Dozer pad
four of your co-workers have been
gathered around your desk for the last
90 seconds also someone named Norm
Scully has been in the bathroom for the
last 72 minutes oh yeah that means he's
about halfway
in regards to the co-workers sir I was
telling them I wanted to get more work
done but all they wanted to do was talk
about my dating life knowing full well
that my true love is efficiency
you know my motto sir chose before hoes
chose his chores
but
I like you I could tell from the moment
I walked in here that we were one in the
same I need to oriented love crunching
numbers but your apartment's Immaculate
probably eat off the floor and I do yeah
man it was for you okay
I'm gonna send out a dozer blast
hey
everyone stopped talking about Peralta's
personal life Dozer blast over
thank you very much sir and might I just
say that this has been a dozer blast I
saw what you did right there
get back to work okay you two have been
in this evidence Locker for nay what
what nothing
you were just making out with Peralta
there's that candy bar wrapper I was
looking for oh Santiago what are you
doing here so I guess it is hose before
it shows with you friend now I
understand why nothing gets done in this
Precinct the detectives are too busy
friendching with each other you know
what your little honeymoon is over
as long as I'm here you two are done and
I'm gonna be here a long long long long
long long long long long long long
oh this is a heart attack this right
here this is a heart attack oh it's a
big one
I'm gonna get help sir
it's all right we're getting help
tell my wife